hello today we're going to be looking at
the Archdruid class and we're gonna be
playing on a randomly generated map so
this is a random map setup we want a
kind of a short intense battle so we're
going to choose eight players and we can
have a small map so it's going to be
kind of like a knife fight in a cupboard
and to speed things up a bit we're going
to choose a battle scenario so we start
with a nice big army so we can get
straight into the action we've also got
some advanced settings we're gonna have
a look at the geography of the place now
we're going to be playing with patron
Ian's today so we want a nice sort of
dragon friendly environment which means
lots of tropics temperate is good no
Arctic don't want any snow no blighted
it's a goblin thing a couple of
volcanoes here and there can't hurt and
yeah that's a bit of water down by the
beach should be okay for now next now
it's a random map all of our leaders our
enemies have been set up randomly as
well so we're gonna see who we can
choose now we're planning today to show
off
resk our draconian Archdruid resk our
scape Schafer we're gonna customize him
a little bit we can still mess about
with him a bit you see there's a female
rest car male race car and you know
maybe give him a hat that's crowned I've
got that very 80s okay nice crown there
and maybe give him a new forms new sort
of forms
lots of horns oh yeah stick with these
ones I like those yeah
very manly and off we go into the world
okay here we are enough freshly created
world with Resco and his little hat so
this is gonna be a free-for-all battle
so somewhere nearby on this map there
are going to be seven other players it's
not the biggest map in the world so
we're gonna run into them quite quickly
so you best get prepared for battle now
here's our starting city race car here
in this capital of nature stir which I
don't speak for Conan very well I'm
afraid
areas and he's got with him some
draconian fires either very powerful de
Canyon infantry one of the best you know
Kenya's themselves can make the
draconian Eldo the kind of priests and
some to Canyon archers who throw
fireballs at people like little AoE
attack also down here we've got another
secondary army we've got some shaman's
there a special arts through a unit they
can charm animals paralyze people and
fro poison bolts oh and looks like
they're invisible in swamp mountain and
flushed and they can swim sort of all
around survival types kind of like Bear
Grylls for the dragon and what else oh
and someone's come to say hello Shan
Shan the Pathfinder who's also an archer
it wants to help us spread nature across
the world right you can come along Shane
okay now first things first and select
production this is our city let's make
some cocoon Yin hatchlings these are
like a very basic laconian units very
cheap very quick babies the draconian
babies that we going to send into battle
but the good things about them is they
evolve if we can rank them up to gold
they will turn into a bigger more
powerful grown-up to Tony in so you know
it's a tough life for a draconian but
you know if they grow up then straight
into the army and what else also want to
do some research at the Coney
ins-and-outs turrets in fact are big on
summoning so you can see here one of the
skills we learn is some an eldritch
animal that's a mid tier summoning spell
that will let us bring in new units to
the battle eldritch will sort of magical
bat creatures so I imagine things like
um I think there's a gigantic poisonous
Pig we can summon yeah let's get that
gigantic poisonous Peaks and see what
magically start where's who we've
already got one as a summon spell summon
wild animal first our domain is quite
useful economic spell cities will grow
faster Sun bursts of blow people up on
the world map always fun
and to begin with in the tactical map we
can throw Spears of people horses nice
what have you got Shane Shane could also
throw Spears people and rust machines
right so here we are so I'm going
exploring looks like there's some farm
over here fathers guarded by some nymphs
and a fairy yeah well I don't think I
really really go much of a match for a
mighty draconian forces auto combat
splat and Hugh and ooh a doggy we've got
a free dog and some magical slimy shoes
of merit evaded blight weakness and
wetland walking and defense okay so they
make us tougher but they also make us
more vulnerable to poison damage and we
can walk through swamps more easily okay
I'll take it
and we've got our doggy our first of
many in our army of animals they'll call
him Rover you can come with us
right keep doing North Sea with us we
can find it's like we found some ancient
ruins now as you can see we get
different prizes from different
structures so hopefully we come over
here just ancient ruins we can then get
something a bit better than some
horrible mud covered shoes and Shane you
can make a little secondary army so you
can join together with this guy what is
what are you Creek 'union Raptor dragons
riding more dragons into battle
excellent and you can take a couple of
shaman's and a couple of flies with you
okay and you go stay here and guard the
Capitol right off we go north to glory
oh I see an enemy or maybe is it who is
it
Oscar Oscar rutila another arts drew art
Detroit city around here have a look
well since she's you know our buddy in
nature we don't need to immediately
declare war
maybe we can sort of make peace with
that maybe she can be our faithful ally
taking on the world so yep peace
treaties been proposal after wait till
next turn fair to respond and go to the
next time okay our first of all new
draconian hatchlings is coming along
making those one for now and let's go up
here into this ruins okay now this is a
special kind of battle we can only bring
the stack that stood on the ruins into
battle so poor Rover is gonna have to
wait outside
okay let's go in and see what we can do
okay piggy doggie and troll to battle
okay here we are in some ancient ruins
and what are we gonna go over there that
piggy and looks like Rovers got a little
fun of the rover's buddies is over at
the back there big hairy wolf seeing
right now sister our streets and friends
with all of the animals and creatures we
have the ability befriend animal which
has a fifty five percent chance of
making us a new piggy pal let's have a
go come on Danny pal right you're with
us now you can sit with Rover but have
our little Zoo full of its around into
battle okay now we can only do that once
a turn so it looks like this guy over
here is it
dead okay now this is only a level one
animal and against a ts3 Baconian slow
he doesn't sound much of a chance we can
forget about him this guy over here
though is slightly more of a problem
he's also Tier three regenerating
dedicated to evil and quite tough
seventeen damage the blow so what we
want them to do is him to won't come to
us give it hit somebody and then we can
gang up on him and take him all down at
once bring the arches up in support we
want to make sure that they can't be he
can't get up to them because he'll
probably attack the squishiest person
first if he can and they were priests
over here priest has in the middle is he
called dragon ancestry protects us
against fire but more importantly sets
[ __ ] gives us a sort of flaming weapon
ability so now our attacks do fire
damage right and turn come on mr. ogre
Gasca little did he know the terrible
terrible fate I have in store for him
first come in and backstab him with
Antonius you can see he does an awful
lot of damage but he's only got 22 hit
points left and rest girls got his
number donk and
okay another victory for the forces of
nature
here's porky he's with us now he can
hang out with Rover and prizes we get a
human Civic guard this is a very low
level human unit melody of oblivious
harmony gives us high morale okay look
at that plant
oh we just carry it with us I don't even
need to equip okay look look you have
one happy race car so you can see here
that Resco since he's found a battle and
since he has this magical book of
happiness he has brettly has very high
morale which means that as you get into
a fight he's more likely to give
critical hits and things like that
that's good and here's a little buddy
new little human Ally fighting in this
mountain send him over to guard the home
base points for this turn back over here
it looks like we are now at peace with
Oscar she has accepted our proposal
okay now pieces nice let's see if we can
taken any further see if we can actually
get their alliance with her now
currently our relationship is polite so
maybe we need to give her something
which to make it like us a bit more we
can't give us a cap at all he'd give her
money and gold a manor or something
nerve or we could give her the slimy
shoes of poison I think we should give
her the slimy shoes at poison women love
slimy shoes of poison I know these
things and I'm sure that's going to go
down like a house on fire and Shane what
are you up to
okay looks like you've got a bandit
campaign shoot that for our little after
our new ally the new ally this will
spawn brigands which will attack us
every turn so it's always good to get
rid of that okay and we get hat cowl of
the
well that was that what is Alima news
yeah we'll just take that do it bringer
of goodwill wall units in the hills I'm
again full of hit new ok so this is
gonna reduce our upkeep costs so if you
take a look at this guy
normally he would cost a 16 goal to turn
now is any cost you think over time nice
and Bob the orc go guard to homestead
keep heading north
hey we got over here goes line for Jane
yep units tremble in fear before me they
are trying to flee the bat what are we
gonna do well they are elves and elves
are very foresty and I do like elves on
the other hand I really dislike mercy so
I will just choose no mercy and active
evil what this little red sign means and
my guys sucks to be you they killed my
dragon well I'm glad I didn't show you
anywhere Oh get some free gold
anyway now that was an act of evil so if
you look over here you'll see our
current in the alignment is neutral they
do not like the fact we hunted turn
flame guards and we apparently have
killed something that's dedicated to
good however we've also killed something
which is dedicated to evil so you know
it'll bounce it out in the end circle of
life and whatnot and then keep wandering
over here and oh another independent
city burger we'll deal with them later
see some also a little oh look
hello Shane so he's got some new skills
you can give himself savage rage and
ability which buffs and animals but
unfortunately he's not with the animals
so um we'll just give him the friend
animal always good always need more
animal friends and we'll make him a bit
tougher all of these strengths okay now
back over
explore to the south we'll send our
little zoo crew Grover and Porky know
down here and see what they can find
move points shame
okay now Hawks wicked Oh pay them give
them some money how much what they want
they'd want 35 gold open borders
generally a nice thing to do you know
making peace alternately we could just
rampage in there and steal this stuff
what we're going to do okay i free
cities for me thank you very much once
again you'll notice evil declared war
but now we have a nice new city it's
occupied so well just one of those were
here will migrate at draconian sigh
don't really like hogs very much always
need more dragons yep and once again
even more evil you know stop great horns
in I mean hope you've already got horns
good anyway um an turn and again Oh
quark oh she declined a proposal hateful
it could have been beautiful cross go
anyway please my life has changed to the
evils apparently the game is not
impressed with my rows of freeform
approach to morality
so anyway continuing our little trip
south looks like our little piggy
buddies had a bit of a roadblock as
powerful as a baby the wolf traveling
together on happy goodwill adventure are
there not quite powerful enough to take
on this small army gold in this gold
mine so they're gonna need some support
before they can break in there and you
guys are a little bit too far away
nice we can send the florid but I'd be
pretty
looks like it you can just make it no
time to attack we can attack next time
and over up here we've got a new city um
I guess we should probably guard on you
city against a newfound enemy I assume
that you're going to be quite upset over
my sudden declaration of war and she had
a bigger army that mean she's got wooden
balls
so we'll just um yeah let's run back
over here and what's going on down here
okay right I think since we've got this
cleared this up here we can actually
make it builder and send it up there to
make a fortress and that will get us ten
more knowledge that was some search
thing in France yeah oh speaking of
research summon Elberton wall has been
researched excellent so the next thing
along the chain of units we can build is
produced Shaymin always nice but I think
we want Druidry we want most of the
casting points so that will speed up how
quickly we can summon things summon
eldritch animal 3 turns 80 Manor
okay so I have to wait for that and
go garlic I think you can have an angry
dwarf coming to visit you soon anyway
okay so it's like a little zoo crew yeah
right fine porky no oh well even lose
the sword dies by the sword and you get
some girls and you get a gold - face it
sir it's a fair exchange you will be
remembered porky you will be remembered
and we found another player who are you
Oh drink another elf didn't end well the
last time we met an elf but let's see
what are you either cred not
dreadnaughts aren't very big on nature
nineteen is gonna end well for you is it
mr. Aldrin not well at all okay so we
just move into his territory here a gold
mine is his sit on top of that we'll cut
off some of his income and Wow he's got
a big army he's got Hell's as Griffin's
elves with guns that was unicorns and
attack and the war robot good I think we
might have to come back a little bit
later but don't you worry
Audrey will fall when I return with my
army of dread spider queens giant Eagles
horned gods and dire penguins